i guess we have to begin with the royal
family because that's what everyone's
talking about i know you've been
i've been very vocal you've you've been
on top of it so i have two questions
um and and the first one is a serious
question because i really i'm hoping you
can
shed some light on this why does anyone
care about these
god-awful people so we'll start with
that why do you think people care that
much
so i have to say i never had an
appreciation for the royals
right it's just it's something that
americans don't really jive with it
never made sense to me
uh but i fell in love and married an
englishman right and uh
so i kind of learned to appreciate the
significance of the queen
and really understanding that there has
been there's been something in their
country
that has remained solid and has not
changed over time
difficult for americans to comprehend
because we are we don't really do
tradition we're kind of like
tear it down old building turn it down
tear it down build something new tear it
down build something new
um so that's the reason i think people
follow the royals now i
i don't care at all for the harry and
megan thing except for the political
undertones of somebody saying
i'm not liked therefore it's because i'm
25
black like that that stuff bothers me
whether it's or you know we're talking
about
democrats saying it we see that
pollution all throughout hollywood
so this hollywood star going into a
country that really sort of
loves its traditions uh and then
accusing them of being fundamentally
racist it's just like
let's keep the american bs race
narrative at least within
within the bounds of america let's not
extend it overseas to europe because
they have a different culture there
they've been around much longer you know
england never had slaves
in its country and by the way in terms
of worldwide slavery the englishmen were
the first to abolish it so she
just sort of relying on american
ignorance and the race obsession in
america and extending it
extending it overseas it's just it's
really bothersome
so do you think uh the american media
running to meghan markle's defense do
you think part of that is their
how they detest tradition in general and
so they don't like the royal family for
that reason
yeah i mean think about where we are
right now in america like right that is
sort of this like cultural marxist
everything that is from yesterday is
wrong it needs to be tore down
everything about america is wrong we got
to get rid of christopher columbus dr
seuss is racist
uh you know so we are just obsessed with
thinking that everything from the past
is wrong
and sure there were elements in the past
that were definitely wrong
but in many ways we've thrown out the
baby with the with the bathwater
and um england is just a different place
right i mean
their population it's there's only three
percent black people in england it's a
remarkably you know
compared to america a very small country
um and so
it just sends it's just it's so ignorant
it's just the height of ignorance to me
uh to have this
d-list actress that nobody knew go over
there
not her race is not discernible by the
eye you if she walked in you would never
say meghan markle is a black woman
right and then she says her son who if
you've seen a picture of
and you think that he has faced um
anti-black racism in his life then i'm a
nigerian prince and i have
you know an account that you can give
you can send some money into
um it's just it's just it's it's
frustrating i think we're just tired of
the race narrative
here in america and it's just obnoxious
that we sent this girl over here to
start
to start the same thing overseas